[Music]
thus the object is in part immediate
being or in general a thing
corresponding to immediate Consciousness
in part another ring of itself its
relationship or being for an other and
being for itself that is determinedness
corresponding to perception and in part
essence or in the form of a universal
corresponding to the understanding it is
as a totality a syllogism or the
movement of the universal through
determination to individuality as also
the reverse movement from individuality
through superseded individuality or
through determination to the universal
it is therefore in accordance with these
three determinations that Consciousness
must know the object as itself however
this knowing of which we are speaking is
not knowing as pure comprehension of the
object that is in terms of the notion
here this knowing is to be indicated
only in its process of coming to be or
in the moments of that aspect of it
which belongs to Consciousness as such
the moments of the notion proper or of
pure knowing in the form of shapes of
consciousness
for this reason the object does not yet
appear in Consciousness as such as the
spiritual essentiality we have just
affirmed it to be and the relationship
of Consciousness to it is not the
consideration of it in this totality as
such nor in its pure form as notion but
it is from one side a shape of
Consciousness as such and from the other
side a number of such shapes which we
bring together in which the totality of
the moments of the object and of the
relation of Consciousness to it can be
indicated only as resolved into its
moments
paragraph 789 is picking up right from
where the first paragraph of this new
section absolute knowing was leading us
into it's got a reference here thus the
object the gag inched on right and we're
going to look at the different
dimensions of that in just a moment and
it's shorter than this lead-in paragraph
but I would say there's actually just as
much going on so we need to linger over
this or if you want to make a hegelian
joke we need to tarry with the negative
going back to the preface you know a
little bit and what is this paragraph
ultimately about well it's about
absolute knowing and Hegel is
contrasting in the heart of this
paragraph uh two different what should
we call them modalities or ways or you
know uh
consciousnesses of knowing a vision
right and we should pause for a second
and think about absolute knowing right
so this is the final section of the
phenomenology it's quite short it's
supposed to be the culmination of this
entire process that we've gone through
with all of these as we're going to see
referenced here shapes gestalten of
Consciousness that as phenomenologists
we had to examine and observe and that
Hegel takes historical humanity and the
development of our Consciousness to have
been working itself out in right so
we're going to come back to that in a
moment but what is this contrast
this is about halfway through this
particular paragraph where he says this
knowing of which we are speaking the Now
The Knowing of which the radar the the
discourse is
is not knowing as pure comprehension of
the object that is in terms of the
notion that's uh Miller's gloss on it so
it's not completely conceptual yet you
know we made this transition very
explicitly at the end of the religion
section religion is about four stellen
or representation or picture thinking
however you like an imagination and we
need to make it conceptual thinking
right
we're not quite there even though we are
in this section right so it's not purely
conceptual or notional it's not pure
comprehension of the object
instead he says here this knowing is to
be indicated or pointed at quite
literally only in its process of coming
to be now process of coming to be is a
little bit of a pleonasm Hegel doesn't
use a word like process in there as a
matter of fact it's just Zionism
is a very important verb in German right
it means to become to come on the scene
to develop right to change in in a kind
of process right so you could say
process is already built into that and
so that is what our knowledge here is
going to be of right The Knowing is to
be indicated only in its process to be
or in the moments of that aspect of it
which belongs to Consciousness as such
and we'll come back to that in a moment
but because he says a few other things
about that as well
and I do want to remind us that
absolute knowing as a word is kind of
productively ambiguous the absolute is
part of what we are trying to develop
vision of right but that absolute
includes us it includes our
you know interlocking
uh developing
culture we could say not just of
individual places like say Germany or
France but of rationality and spirit
more generally which of course Hegel you
know Associates with Europe he's clearly
eurocentric but we don't necessarily
have to follow him in that so you know
our absolute knowing is knowing of the
absolute but it's also
absolute knowing in a sense on the
subject The Knowing subject side
knowing in an absolute way and that's
what we're trying to get to and that is
going to involve you could say a
recuperation and reconfiguration of the
previous shapes of Consciousness that we
have gone through so far and in this
particular paragraph It's the shapes of
Consciousness as we find them in the
Consciousness section the very early
part of the work right so Hegel is
coming back and doing something you've
seen him do in the phenomenology several
times referencing back and saying oh by
the way we didn't leave behind entirely
these previous Dynamics and developments
and dialectics of Consciousness keep
them in your back pocket as superseded
as sublated alcohol business because
you're going to need them later on here
is where we actually do need them so
coming back to the beginning of this he
talks about the object the gagenstand
and he says it is partly or in part
right and he uses this word three times
tiles so this is saying you got this
over here you got this over here and you
got this over here just like we've
diagrammed right we have
immediate being and what is immediate
being and it's just a straightforward
translation of zines
so you know this is one part of the
object what we're trying to understand
what we're trying to wrap our head
around uh another part is going to be
the other ring of its self right and
then the third part is essence or Vasan
so we have a difference here between
sometimes Vasan gets used or translated
as being here it really is Essence as
opposed to immediate being what it is
the thing is supposed to be right so
let's unpack each of these in turn he
says the object is in part immediate
being or in general helped
a Thing ending really a bunch of things
anything you want right because what are
we talking about here what does this
correspond to so here Hegel uses the
term saying it it corresponds to
immediate Consciousness right
side but what are we really talking
about here sense certainty
all this stuff that we went through with
you know talking about trees and here
and now all that interesting dialectic
that was happening back in the sense
certainty section so we've got a shape
of Consciousness here one which was you
know it went through a lot of
development it's not just oh there it is
you know one one paragraph and we're
done with it we went through a whole you
know set of Decades of paragraphs okay
so then we've got the othering of itself
right
and he tells us this is a little bit
more complex so he says in part and
othering of itself and there's two
you could say aspects to this
it's relationship right for helpness
or being for another or it's just
determinedness
which is being for self and this makes
sense you know relationship does involve
relationship with another if you don't
have another you don't have a
relationship I mean it could be a
self-relationship in which you're
treating yourself as other right it
happens a lot in hegel's dialectics and
determinedness being for self now isn't
it interesting that he ties in
determinantness uh you know taking on
some sort of determinate qualities
um you know configurations in its own
self as being not for another but being
for itself a thing knows itself or
manifests itself indeterminate ways and
here we must be talking about not you
know objects like a piece of chalk or a
tie or a piece of technology technology
even but subjects that are grasping
themselves and then he goes out and he
says well this corresponds to perception
you know and if you think back to the
perception section the second section in
the Consciousness coming right after the
initial uh sense certainty section it is
perception or the perception or the
thing and its qualities right so now
we're trying to understand things in
relation to other things and as
determinate okay good so far you know
understanding that and then we get to
the next one he says or
in you know in part essence
in the form of a universal alga minus
it's not actually saying form here
that's Miller adding that in but
as the universal as something Universal
so the essence as we traditionally
conceive of it you know in philosophy we
often say well what is it that connects
all the beds together and makes them
beds or chairs or human beings or you
know fuzzy Little Creatures we call
squirrels right and we take the the
thing the idea whatever it is that
connects all of them the universal to be
its Essence and so this he says
corresponds to the understanding and
what does he mean by that
force in the understanding actually one
of the most difficult portions of the
phenomenology to which Hegel devotes a
lot of paragraphs and there's more than
just the development of the
understanding or the concept of force
going on there it actually leads to this
dialectic between different worlds all
interconnected with each other and as we
go on from immediate being to Essence we
get a more and more complex picture that
we're working with in which we are
ourselves more and more explicitly
involved so that's a little bit of you
know rehearsal of what went on and then
he says something really really
interesting
he says it is as a totality totality is
a fine translation for ganses a
syllogism or the movement of the
universal through determination to
individuality we'll get to that in a
moment a movement
no problem with that
we need to be careful about this word
syllogism now Hegel is indeed very
interested in the syllogism and in
syllogisms and in the kind of reasoning
processes that go with us and what
syllogisms can produce or reveal to us
but he doesn't say syllogism here he
says schluss right a process and it
could it be a syllogism yes a process of
inference a conclusion quite literally
but he doesn't say syllogism so you want
to be a little bit careful now there are
indeed three terms Hegel does use you
know a really let's say Taking Liberties
sometimes wildly treatment of syllogisms
in the phenomenology he's done that many
many times right you talked about the
middle term and you know what we can
conclude but we don't want to think that
there's something like syllogistic
reasoning going on here the kind of
stuff that you might have studied in a
introduction to logic class because
that's not what is actually happening
it's more a complex process of inference
and it goes both ways right so he talks
about beginning with the universal
and then through determination right
through stem Tides uh into individuality
Einstein height so how do we go from
having things that are Universal and
then determining them and then getting
individual things whether it's the
objects that we're studying like that
fuzzy little squirrel over there who's
you know chewing on something in the
park and maybe we can get them to come
over and give them some nuts or
something
to ourselves
and even bigger things
the process of history as understood
through dialectical Consciousness right
how do we individuate those things and
then we work our way backwards as he
says
um
there we go the universal through
determination to individuality as also
the reverse movement
from individuality through individuality
as superseded alcohol Bena right
important term in the hegelian dialectic
isn't it aufhaven so it supersedes
itself as we've seen it happen many many
times in the course of our studies and
also by the way is happening in the
Consciousness section when you are
reading force in the understanding and
you're realizing that you are one of the
subjects that Hegel is narrating this
not just
two but on the behalf of you could say
you are originally an individual now
you're superseding that and then you get
to the universal this is happening all
the time in the phenomenology without us
explicitly realizing it that's why Hagel
wants to tell us that right here and
right now
so he goes on and he says that
um
it is in accordance with these three
determinations now
what are the three determinations
are they immediate being othering of
itself and essence
I mean
it seems like if we're going to find
determination isn't it already under
othering of ourself
well yes but each of these is a
determination something you know
particular in relation to each other
but it could also be here's where the
ambiguity comes in
individuality determinedness which is
superseded individuality and the
universal so it's actually not clear
from the context and I I would suggest
we should read both of these so he says
that uh in accordance with these three
determinations Consciousness must know
the object
as itself Consciousness must realize
that it is involved in the process of
knowing
the object and the object
includes
all of these as he says moments here we
come back to this knowing of which we're
speaking is not knowing is pure
comprehension of the object that is in
terms of the notion it is indicated only
in its process of coming to be or what
is this process of coming to be the
moments of that aspect of it which
belongs to Consciousness as such the
moments of the notion proper or of pure
knowing in the form of shapes of
Consciousness gestalten right so this is
what we've been studying the entire time
these are moments both understood here
in this paragraph As sort of telescoped
out into the previous uh you know
Consciousness section and as those
shapes as they were worked out in the
same section so those are the moments of
this knowing that we are engaged in
all right so so far so good he goes on
and he says for this reason the object
does not yet appear in Consciousness the
object that we're
trying to begin with the object that has
all of these is it's
components or
moments right for this reason the object
does not yet appear in Consciousness as
such
as the spiritual essentiality right vase
and height that we have just affirmed it
to be so there's something that we still
need to work out you know good thing
there's some more paragraphs Yet to Come
not many of them so we better work it
out quick and he goes in he says and the
relationship of Consciousness to it
is not the consideration of it in this
totality God's height as such nor in its
pure form as notion but now notice what
he's going to say here
it is from one side a shape of
Consciousness as such right so we
scrutinize we follow through
dialectically as phenomenologists a
particular Shape Of Consciousness we
work it through you know we've gone
through all of these very interesting
ones uh throughout the course of
studying the phenomenology it's probably
taken us quite a while we've probably
had to go at it a number of times but
we've got them up in our head we're like
you know at least I understand how the
uh you know phrenology and physiognomy
section works or at least I understand
this reference to the Antigone and the
two laws or at least I understand
freedom and the terror you know or pick
whatever it is that you want so we've
got individual shapes
but there's many of them aren't there
throughout this work so he says from the
other side
a number of shapes which
now notice this we bring together
hegel's been bringing these shapes
together for us in this complex work
he's also saying hey you reader yeah
more than 200 years after I finished
this book
there's a we here we're going along
we're recognizing these different shapes
we're arranging them in relation to each
other we're seeing the connections we're
seeing them as moments of some sort of
object that we understand that we know
right so a number of such shapes which
we bring together in which
the totality of the moments of the
object
object that's all of this stuff here and
of the relationship relation of
Consciousness to it well that's us
I mean you could say the relation of
Consciousness okay they're all part of
the Consciousness section right so that
makes sense but we're Consciousness too
right we're reading that so that we
actually understand what the hell we're
doing when we cognize or relate
ourselves to an object or even to space
and time in general or to you know
properties of things or to a world
right so this is quite important it's
not just the object that has its moments
we are in relation to that object and
that's part of what each of these
moments is unpacking signifying
designating for us and so he goes on and
he says
um in which the totality of the moments
of the object and the relation of
Consciousness to it can be indicated
only as resolved into its moments as
this point we're not yet ready to
synthesize to bring all of this together
to you know sublate everything in some
you know finalized absolute knowing
we're getting closer but we're not quite
there we're working our way
to it towards it into it right so this
is quite an important paragraph and the
paragraphs to come we're going to see
other dialectics other shapes of
Consciousness similarly being
re-examined by Hegel and you might say
put into their proper place but that's
what is happening in this paragraph so
you can see that it's setting the stage
for more to come and from a hegelian
perspective it's also carrying out
a deepening
of our not just understanding but
knowledge of the coming to be of
what happened all these you know objects
for us and our own relation of knowing
to these objects